esports has plenty of heroes but
it has very few gods it takes a lot to
become a god
one of japan's five fighting game gods
some gods arrive
from far away he's the god the op god
they were simply referred to as
gods as for as uh the god of daughter
okay so that might have been a stretch
but
what isn't is how one man became a meme
and transcending it became an object of
adoration an
answerer to prayers everywhere i'm
talking
about our lord lmg mounted
and loaded no not to chanka but
gaben gabe newell is the co-founder and
ceo of valve
the developer and publisher behind
renowned games like half-life
counter-strike dota 2 team fortress 2
and left 4 dead newell went to harvard
for 3 years
but dropped out to work for a little
company called
microsoft known for its operating
systems
and lit launch parties
[Music]
after 13 years there newell went on to
found
valve software with his former microsoft
colleague mike harrington
and over the next decade the company
would become one of the biggest players
in pc gaming but as valve continued to
release both
sequels to existing series and new games
it also branched into
digital game distribution with steam a
platform that would be used for selling
not only valves games but eventually
ones made by other developers too
with the incredible commercial success
of valve
newell became one of the video game
industry's richest people
with a current net worth estimated by
forbes at nearly four billion dollars
show me the money but if gabe newell was
just an executive
we probably wouldn't be covering him in
the series instead
his quirky personality and unique
interests have endeared him to gamers
all around the world so why is that
well for starters he has more knives
than [__] rambo
he isn't afraid to be himself you know
there are like 350 million pcs sold last
year
so the economies of scale are tremendous
so you get great value for your money i
don't know
they're great i have like 12 of them and
most importantly
he doesn't take himself too seriously do
you want to pretend to be ringo
yes i do
gaben is clearly one of us someone who
likes video games and isn't afraid to
own it
but how did he ascend to meme godhood
well newell's transformation into gaben
or lord gaben
began in the late 2000s when team
fortress 2
released with the developer commentary
mode featuring the man himself
please let me know what you think after
you have had a chance to play
i can be reached at gaben
valvesoftware.com
and my favorite class is the spy thanks
and have fun
so his name and email are really the
source of the moniker itself
but the meme really took off between
and 2012.
take control i can be reached
[Music]
at valvesoftware.com but perhaps the
most defining image of the game and meme
is the so-called lord gaben portrait
created by fred dre
which was quickly remixed into the
wildly popular tonight's the night video
and so gaben evolved from a silly
nickname
into a full-blown religious cult figure
i'm pregnant with miracles today with
the rampant success
and popularity of steam gaben is often
seen as a steward of pc gaming
so when a steam sale happens it is seen
as his
generous bidding but gavin's blessing is
also
a curse as the sales often cause your
wallet
to hemorrhage money
and let's be honest guys how many of you
have actually completed
every game in your steam library
[Music]
another aspect of gaben's mystical
nature
is an aversion to the number three
anyhow
thank you very much i have a light
flashing at me telling me that i don't
get to answer the third question
the line is triple kill triple three is
then you've killed
three heroes you've killed more than
two people and less than four
[Music]
this is because so far valve hasn't made
a game in a series
that was numbered as the third game
half-life 2
episode 3 nah cancelled left 4 dead 3
nope team fortress 3 keep dreaming
half-life 3
but how has gaben taken his fame and
newfound divinity
hilariously well actually while he might
be worth billions
you get the sense that gaben is still
one of us this is perhaps
most apparent when a couple of my
canadian countrymen
journeyed to valve's office in bellevue
washington to protest the lack of a
half-life 2
episode 3 release you know we thought it
was awesome we wanted them to stay
so you know we took them pizza and
they'd only brought two sodas and
they're planning on being there for two
days
so we got them stuff to drink they're
very nice
you know very passionate about our games
but despite his general benevolence lord
gaben has
shown that he can be a vengeful god too
and it would be a mistake for us to not
mention his involvement
in the james's and ass controversy of
2016.
during the absolute [__] show that was
the shanghai major
james two good harding the event's desk
host caught gaben's attention
for his off-color on-air antics i am sir
too good your house for this event but
don't worry as always it's not just
me here to talk about the do's and
don'ts of dota 2 and the cans of [__]
of the teams
turned out you know censorship the
chinese hotel
the same had disabled pornography don't
get me wrong i watched it
mr wang's amazing wheelchair antics were
pretty amazing
you know i know i got the hosting gig
you know admittedly
you know red eyes a bit wiser and i'm
not as hands-on i think your name
your name was wrong it shouldn't be sir
too it should be old
you can [__] off gaben didn't find
too good's material to be particularly
amusing and his
wrath would be swift as two good would
be immediately terminated and berated
shortly thereafter
in a hilarious reddit post gaben giveth
but gaben also taketh away but ever
since that incident he's only become a
more popular and pronounced figure
within the dota 2 community
and year after year gaben continues to
welcome crowds
to the international dota's biggest
tournament
to canada
if that's not enough he was even added
to the game as an
announcer in 2018. please email me at
gaben
valvesoftware.com and let me know about
your rampage
gaben is the lord because he blesses us
our steam libraries
runneth over and if you pray really hard
something on your wish list might go on
sale or maybe your next case
will have a knife in it a sure sign of
gaben's blessing
just don't hold your breath waiting for
half-life 3 because it's
never gonna happen
what the [__] is that sorry just setting
up the half-life 3 announcement alarm
we have an alarm for that we have alarms
for a lot of things
still waiting for the t lizard breaks
100k alarm to go off though
yeah i'll take my chances on the
half-life 3 alarm going off first
home is not a better movie it's not even
a better comedy
than ghostbusters
i can't i can't agree i can't agree
what episode was it where i wore the
smocking shirt
it was it was nuke right yeah it was
nuke
everybody who watched the nuke video you
know that ghostbusters is a better film
and miles is full of [__]
so i even use a ghostbusters clip in the
new
script because you had to edit that [__]
right
there you go [__] well i know i had no
comeback i had no good argument